the FBI and US Marshals meantime are
involved in a massive manhunt for a
violent psychiatric patient who escaped
from an island in Hawaii in a chartered
plane video from inside a taxi cab shows
Randall Saito fleeing from the Hawaii
State Hospital Sunday he left the island
of Oahu and later flew to California
Saito was committed to the hospital in
1981 two years after he was acquitted of
murder by way of insanity
officials say he is dangerous and should
not be on the streets
vladimir duthiers is our streaming
network cbsn is following the story Vlad
good morning good morning Saito was
charged with the murder of 29 year-old
Sandra Yamashiro in 1979 after he
allegedly stock shot and stabbed her in
a shopping mall parking lot officials
have yet to explain how a man in state
custody for nearly 40 years
managed to get to the US mainland or why
it took hours for police to learn of his
escape this security camera image shows
Randall Saito leaving the Hawaii State
Hospital empty-handed around 9:00 a.m.
on Sunday before meeting a cab at the
Kaneohe district park about a mile away
dashcam video obtained by her Honolulu
affiliate KGMB shows Saito getting into
the cab now carrying a large backpack
and a cell phone later he asked his
driver to hurry
at about 10:30 a.m. Saito pays for a
chartered flight to Maui in cash from
there he hops on a twelve twenty five pm
Hawaiian Airlines flight to San Jose
California that police say he booked
online using an alias Saito lands in San
Jose two hours before state health
officials report him missing
he still has ability or Honolulu
prosecutor way into Shima successfully
argued against allowing Saito to receive
uh Ness courted off-site privileges in
2015 because of the risk of danger he
posed we weren't comfortable with him
being out there even with anis Esquire
officials warn that Saito is dangerous
and should not be approached and I'm not
going to get into the details I'm sorry
at this point I just can't on Tuesday ye
state hospital administrators would not
comment on why it took more than ten
hours to report Saito missing and we
need complete information before we're
willing to share that and sharing that
has got to be coordinated with criminal
investigation components there are still
several questions still unanswered like
how Saito got the bag the phone and the
cash it's also unclear how he booked
both flights and how he made it through
airport security using an alias our
Honolulu affiliate KGMB says it has
obtained documents that say in 1993
Saito engaged in sexual relationships
with at least three members of the
hospital staff and was able to receive
contraband Gale all right a lot of
questions here Thank You Vlad